[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: All right.
So last time, we proved
the fundamental theorem
of calculus.
And as a consequence,
integration by parts of formula
and the change of variables
formula or use substitution.
So let me just recall,
for integration by parts,
it was that if I have two
continuously differentiable
functions, then I can shift the
burden of taking a derivative.
F prime times g integrate
is equal to f of b, g of b,
minus f of a, g of a, minus
the interval from a to b of g
prime f.
So I can shift that
derivative over from f to g.
And this is apart from
the triangle inequality,
probably one of the most
useful theorems that comes out
of calculus other than
the fundamental theorem
of calculus.
In fact, for those of you who've
taken quantum mechanics, which
I mean, you don't have to.
But or you heard of something
called the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle, which
says something like something
to the effect that you
cannot measure the position
of a particle and its momentum
to arbitrarily good degree,
you're bound by if you
can measure the position
of a particle very well,
then your measurement
of the momentum is going to be
not so great and vice versa.
And that's based
on an inequality,
and how do you prove
that inequality?
Integration by parts.
So integration by
parts is, in fact,
responsible for one of
the great head-scratchers
from quantum mechanics.
So just to back up my
claim a little bit.
Now, I'm not going to give
that as an application.
I'm going to give a different
application related to Fourier
series.
So the Fourier series,
what are these?
So suppose we have a function.
And I'm not going
to say what type.
Suppose f from minus pi to
pi to R is 2 pi periodic.
And so, the question
that arose due to Fourier
in his study of heat transfer--
so this is Fourier,
I don't know,
something like 200 years ago.
He made the following claim,
that the function f of x
can be expanded in terms
of simpler building blocks,
in terms of simpler functions.
So we haven't talked
about Taylor series.
We will in just a
minute, or power series,
which you've come
into contact with,
which is a way of, if you like,
expanding a function in terms
of polynomials.
And now-- or monomials.
Now, Fourier
suggested that f of x
can be expanded as a
superposition of functions
which are 2 pi periodic and
kind of the most basic 2
pi periodic functions.
Now, what is so special
about sine x and cosine x?
Well, this is a
little bit deeper,
the fact that they satisfy
certain second order
differential equation.
And they are all of the
solutions to the second order
differential equation
that are 2 pi periodic.
So you should think of these as
kind of being building blocks.
Another way to think
of this is analogous to
for if you have a vector, so
now this is not a partition.
This is a vector,
x1, x2, xn, then
you can expand this vector
as a sum of coefficients
a sub n, a sub j,
j equals 1 to n.
You know what?
Let me make this M. Let's make
this N. Let's make this M,
so it looks a little--
a sub n, e sub,
where now, e sub n
this is the basis
vector given by 0 1 0
where this is in the end spot.
So you can think
of this expansion
in terms of sines
and cosines as being
analogous to expanding a vector
in terms of basis elements.
Or you can think of
it as a different way
to expand a function other than
Taylor series or power series.
But these components
arose in a natural way
if one were to study the
problem of heat transfer, which
is governed by the equation
dtu equals dx squared u.
And then, along with an initial
condition, that u of 0x,
so at time 0, equals f of x.
So now, just like for how we
expand a vector into basis
elements, there's a formula for
computing these coefficients.
So they should be a sub n
should be x sub n over here.
But what's a different way of
obtaining these coefficients?
So this is a vector in RM.
And so, how do you obtain
the coefficients a sub n?
Well, if I take the inner
product of both sides,
the dot product, say of e
x dot, let's say, e sub n
prime, let's say--
so I've used Mn, let's say l.
This is equal to the sum from n
equals 1 to the M of a sub n, e
sub n dot e sub l.
Now, I wrote these basis vectors
this way, because that's kind
of a standard choice for RM.
And what makes them standard
is, they have unit length.
And they're orthogonal
to each other.
So they form in
orthonormal basis.
So when I take the product
of e sub n with e sub l,
I pick up what is usually
referred to as delta in l.
Where here, delta in l, this
is 1 if n equals l, and 0 if n
does not equal l.
And therefore, this
just reduces to a l.
So we see that a sub l is
equal to x dot e sub l.
And so, all of
this discussion was
in the setting of a finite
dimensional vector in RM.
And expanding in terms of
the standard basis here.
But it didn't have to be.
It could have been as long
as it's an orthonormal basis,
then I get this relation,
that the coefficient that
appears in front
of that vector is
equal to the thing I'm
interested in dotted
with that vector,
which is written here.
So let's say we try and do
the same thing now with f
of x, except now and say--
so these are functions.
So instead of
taking dot products,
which is a sum of components,
let's take an integral.
So if I take f of
x and, if you like,
dot it with sine
of x in sum, which
is-- you can think of as I
said that the integral is,
you should think of as
maybe a continuous sum.
What do we get assuming
that this expansion holds,
this is equal to the
sum from n equals 0.
So let me make this l.
This is the sum from n equals
0 to infinity of a sub n
sine n, x times sine.
So let me-- forgetting to
write the integrals here.
Skipping a point I
want to make as well.
Sum, and just remember the sum
is starting from 0 to infinity.
I don't want to keep writing it.
a n sine n x sine l x plus bn
cosine in x sine n l x, sine x.
And then, n equals
0 to infinity.
I'll just write it.
Stop being lazy.
Now, assuming I can do
what I'm about to do,
and that's actually going to
be a lot of the motivation
for what we're going to
discuss in our final chapter,
assuming I can take
this infinite sum
and interchange it
with this integral,
this is the interchanging
of two limits.
The sum is the infinite limit.
An integration is a limit.
So assuming I can switch
these two limiting processes,
then I pick up a sub n minus pi
to pi, sine in x, sine in lx,
sine lx, sorry, plus b sub n
integral minus pi to pi, cosine
in x, sine lx dx.
Now, you can actually sit
down and compute this based
on trigonometric identities.
And what you get is that
this is always equal to 0.
And that this here equals
pi times delta in l.
So this equals the
sum from n equals 0
to infinity a n pi delta in
l, which equals pi times al.
So we get this quantity here is
assuming everything we've done
is kosher equal to
pi times a sub l.
And then, to pick up
the b sub l is the same,
except now you integrate
against cosine of lx.
So similarly, pi
times b sub l is
equal to the integral
from minus pi
to pi of f of x cosine lx dx.
So the b sub l's and a sub l's
are referred to as a Fourier
coefficients of the function f.
So if f from minus pi to
pi to R is continuous,
and 2 pi periodic, the
numbers a sub n equals 1
over pi, integral from minus
pi to pi of f of x sine nx, dx,
b sub n equals 1 over pi,
integral from minus pi to pi,
f of x cosine in x, dx are
referred to as the Fourier
coefficients of f.
And so, just using
integration by parts,
so what's the first
question one should
ask if it's even possible,
or in what sense does
f of x equal this infinite sum?
Well, we haven't even
gotten into that.
But one question you can ask
is, do these coefficients that
come in front of these
basic building blocks,
sine nx and cosine nx,
do they converge to 0?
I mean, if we
expect f of x to be
equal to the sum of
these basic parts,
then the contributions
from each should
be getting smaller and smaller.
So does a n and bn tend to
0 as n goes to infinity?
And this is the
content of what's
usually referred to as the
Riemann-Lebesque lemma.
But it's usually stated
in a different way.
I'm just going to state
it this way right now.
And which is the following.
If f from ab to R is
continuously differentiable,
then limit as n goes
to infinity of a sub n
equals the limit as n goes to
infinity of b sub n equals 0.
Now, the actual way the
Riemann-Lebesque lemma
is typically stated
is, in fact, I
don't need it to be
continuously differentiable.
I just need it to be continuous.
This is still true.
But we haven't done--
or won't do in this
class approximation
theorems for
continuous functions.
Which says that
if you can do this
for continuously
differentiable functions,
then basically you can do
it for continuous functions.
But this will suffice.
So what this says is that
the contributions coming
from these building
blocks is getting smaller,
at least in the sense
that the coefficients are
getting smaller.
But it says nothing about
if that sum up there
with the a n's and bn's
defined this way actually
converges to f.
I do want to emphasize that, in
fact, trying to straighten out
this question, in what
sense this series converges
to f is really the motivation
for a lot of analysis
developed past in the first
part of the last century
and the last part of
the century before that
and forms the basis of what's
called harmonic analysis.
Which is a really
beautiful subject
and still an active area
of ongoing research.
So how do we prove this?
Well, I stated the integration
by parts formula earlier.
So in fact, it'll follow
pretty easily from that.
Let's prove that the limit
as n goes to infinity
of b sub n equals 0.
The one for a sub n is similar.
There's just an extra piece.
But I'm going to be a little
bit lazy and do the easier one.
We'll show-- so let's
look at b sub n.
This is equal to the integral
from minus pi to pi of f of x.
And in fact, let me write
cosine nx times f of x, dx, dx.
Why am I writing dx, dx?
And now what I do
is, cosine nx, I
can write as the
derivative of something.
1 over n times sine nx.
If I take the derivative
of that with respect to x,
I get cosine nx.
I didn't actually prove that.
But you can look back in
your calculus textbooks.
We've proven enough to be
able to make that precise.
So by integration by parts,
I can now shift the blame,
or shift the burden of
this derivative onto f.
But look what I've gained.
I've gained 1 over n here.
So now, this is equal
to 1 over n sine n pie,
f of pi minus sine of n
minus pi times f of pi--
minus pi, sorry-- minus 1 over
n sine nx minus pi to pi, f
prime of x, dx.
And really, what this
competition is showing is--
illustrating is the oscillatory
nature of what's going on.
Cosine of nx is oscillating as n
gets very large between minus 1
and 1 and equal footing.
So on average, you're
getting the same amount
of positive f as minus--
as negative f.
So or you're weighting
f in such a way
that it's both positive and
negative in equal amounts.
Now, sine of n pi, no
matter what n is, I get 0.
Sine of n of minus pi, I get 0.
So this first part drops off.
So this is equal to minus 1
over n, minus pi, pi, sine
in x, times f prime of x, dx.
And therefore, if I take the
absolute value of b sub n,
this is less than or equal
to 1 over n minus pi over pi,
sine in x f prime of x, dx.
If I bring the
absolute value inside,
so I can bring the absolute
value inside and still get
this.
So in fact, before when I had
the absolute value outside,
it's the equality.
But now it's a less
than or equality--
I mean, an inequality.
So now, sign of nx is
always bounded by 1.
So this is less than or
equal to the integral of f
prime of x, dx.
So this is equal to 1
over n integral a, b, f.
Now, this is just f prime.
This is just a fixed
number times 1 over n.
So this converges to 0
as n goes to infinity.
And b sub n, an absolute
value, of course,
it's always bigger
than or equal to 0.
And it's bounded by
something converging
to 0 as n goes to infinity.
So by the squeeze
theorem, we conclude
b sub n converges to 0.
And that's the proof.
The proof for the a
sub n's is similar,
except now you can't throw
away necessarily the endpoints.
But it's still not
a very big deal.
And in fact, if we have time,
I'll show you how much--
so in fact, one can prove-- and
this is proven in classes on--
courses on harmonic
analysis, that in fact,
for a function which is
continuously differentiable,
this-- and 2 pi
periodic-- this series
actually does converge
uniformly to f on this interval.
And I haven't even said what
uniform convergence means.
But actually does converge
to the function f of x.
So this is the case for
continuously differentiable
functions.
I'll give a proof later
that, in fact, this series
converges if f is twice
continuously differentiable.
We can actually do that
using the fundamental--
the integration by parts
again, essentially.
But so, but there
are a few things here
that are behind the scene
that are kind of swept away.
First off, when we computed
these formulas-- formulae,
I guess--
we interchanged summation,
infinite summation of functions
with integration.
When can we do that?
In what sense does if this
Fourier series converges,
in what sense does
it converge to f?
For convergence of
real numbers, there
was just one sense of the
convergence of real numbers.
Now, when we have a sequence
of functions, which is now
what we're going
to turn to, we'll
have different
notions of convergence
to another function.
And depending on in what
sense that conversion--
that convergence
takes place, some
of these limiting operations
may not interchange.
So now, we're going to move
on to the final chapter
of this class.
And I know it seems
like we're kind
of hitting a lot
of different things
now towards the
end of the class.
And we took it slow during
the first part of class.
But that's, like
I said, that's--
I think I even said this
at the start of class.
We didn't have very
much to go off of.
We built things
from the ground up.
And the more
technology you have,
the more things you can prove,
the more interesting questions
you can ask.
So now, we're going to go on
to sequences of functions.
And you could also put
sequences and series.
Because a series is
just a special type
of sequence of functions.
So I motivated a
little bit of why
we would be interested
in functions converging
to other functions or sequences
of functions converging
to a function.
But we could look at
something much more basic.
So let's take a step back
and look at power series.
And this should be
thought of as motivation
for what's to come, just like
our discussion about Fourier
series.
And again, I'm not going to
ask any questions about Fourier
series on the homework
or on the exam.
So a lot of this is just--
this discussion was to
motivate this theorem here.
But now, I'm going to
make a kind of a more
precise motivation, I
guess, for what's to come.
So although we've
had series forever,
I never brought up power series.
And it's for a reason.
It's because I didn't think
they belonged anywhere until we
got to sequences of functions.
So a power series
about a point x0
is a series of the form sum from
j equals 0 to infinity of a sub
j, x minus x0 to the j.
So the x0 is given.
And the things that could
change are the coefficients
or this number x here.
So theorem, which
immediately follows
from essentially the root test.
Suppose, this number R,
which is the limit as j
goes to infinity of a
sub j, 1 over j exists.
So it's a finite number,
positive, not negative number.
And define rho to be 1 over
R if R is bigger than 0,
and infinity if R equals 0.
Then we have the
following conclusion,
that this power series a
sub j converges absolutely
if x minus x0 is less
than rho, and diverges
if x minus x0 in absolute
value is bigger than rho.
And this number rho, we refer
to as radius of convergence.
So again, the proof
follows immediately
from the root test because
if we take a limit as j
goes to infinity of a
sub j, absolute value
x minus x0 j, 1 over j,
this is equal to x minus x0.
This kills that j.
This is just a fixed number.
So this pops out of the limit.
And this limit exists.
So this equals x
minus x0 times R.
And we have two
things happening.
This is less than 1 if x
minus x0 is less than rho,
bigger than 1 if x minus
x0 is bigger than rho--
this number here.
And therefore, by the root
test, the theorem holds.
So we see that this series,
where the, if you like,
what's given are the
coefficients a sub j and x0,
and what could change is x, that
this series converges as long
as x minus x0 is less than rho.
So as long as we stay--
[SNEEZES] excuse me.
As long as we stay in that
interval, a symmetric interval
about x0, then this series
converges, absolutely.
So we can define
a function where
if I take x in this interval,
stick it into this series,
I get out a number.
So define function f now
going from this interval.
So x0 minus rho, x0
plus rho to R by f of x
equals the number that gets
spat out by this power series.
[INAUDIBLE] j there.
So for example, what is f of x?
Let's say I take all of
the coefficients to be--
let's say, x0 is 0, and
all the coefficients are 1.
So let's say I look
at sum of x sub j.
Then f of x, so we've
already computed
for a geometric series.
This is equal to 1 over 1
minus x for x in minus 1, 1.
So in the simple setting, 1 over
1 minus x is equal x to the j.
Another example
is, that if I take
a sub j equals 1 over j
factorial, x0 equals 0,
then you've done
this in an exercise,
that this series here
converges absolutely for all x.
And meaning rho equals infinity.
And this is how we define
the exponential function.
Exponential
function, exponential
of x to be what comes
out of this series.
And then, simply
from this definition,
you can show things that an
exponential function should
satisfy, x e to the n is
equal to n e to the e of 1
to the n-th power,
and so on, and so on.
So that this really does
obey what you believe
an exponential function
should look like.
And also, it grows
faster than any power
of x as x goes to infinity, goes
to 0, those types of things.
But this is how the exponential
function is defined.
So we have this function that's
defined by whatever this power
series spits out, for x inside
this interval of convergence.
So then, I could write
f of x as the limit
as n goes to infinity of
a sequence of functions.
Because this is just how
it's defined, where fn of x
is the partial sum.
It's just a polynomial.
So for power series,
the limiting function,
you can write it as the limit
of the partial sums, which
are just polynomials.
And so, I should say, for all x
in this interval, we have this.
So now, some questions arise.
So what this function is
equal to, the limit of these
maybe simpler functions.
These simpler functions
are just polynomials
for the case of power series.
So like I said, 1
over 1 minus x is
equal to the limit
of these polynomials.
Some questions should arise.
I mean, analysis
is about limits.
You can think of that
as half the story.
First off, what is the limit?
What are important limiting
processes that we consider?
The second question is, how
do different limits interact?
So let's pose that
as a question now
for a three-parted
question for power series.
And this will motivate--
and this is, again,
motivating all of what
we're going to be doing now.
So is the function that I get
as this limit of polynomials
as the output from a power
series, is it continuous?
The individual
pieces that I take
a limit to get f of x, these
polynomials or the partial sums
are certainly continuous.
They're just polynomials.
So is the limiting
thing continuous?
Now, if so, is f differentiable?
And in particular, since
f is equal to the limit
as n goes to infinity of
the fn's, is f prime equal
to the limit as n goes to
infinity of the fn prime?
So the derivative is
a limiting process.
So I'm taking the
derivative of the limit.
So I'm asking, can I take that
derivative inside the limit?
Can I swap the two processes?
And the same with integration.
If one, does the integral
of f equal limit as n goes
to infinity of the
integrals of the fn's?
So again, this is
a limiting process
that we're asking us to flip,
because f is equal to the limit
as n goes to infinity of fn.
And what I'm asking is,
can I take this integral
inside that limit?
Now, you can ask these questions
not just for power series,
but in a more general
setting, which is what
we're going to turn to now.
But this should be in
the back of your mind
as the motivation
for what we're doing.
And apart from being just
an academic question,
it's also somehow
giving you information
over whether the formal
manipulations that you're
doing with Fourier series that
are actually somehow modeling
some physical phenomenon, are
these formal manipulations even
meaningful?
So these are the
three questions that
motivate what we're going
to do going forward.
But we don't have to
just stick to the setting
of being in power series.
This should be a very
important example
of a sequence of
functions converging
to a function, a
limiting function.
And then, we can
ask these questions.
But we don't have to just
stick to power series.
So let me move on to a more
general setting in which we'll
answer these three questions.
And two modes of convergence
for limits of functions
or sequences of functions.
So first definition, this
is, in fact, what we showed
or what we were talking about
before for N natural number,
let fn be a function
from S to R. S
is some non-empty subset
of the real numbers.
And let f be from S to R.
We say, fn-- so the sequence
of functions fn converges
point-wise to the function
f if for all x in S,
by sticking x into S, so
for each fixed x in S,
if I stick this into
fn of x, I get a limit.
And this limit is f of x.
So for example, going
back to power series,
if we defined f of x--
so let me just rewrite that
example that I had up there.
If I define f of
x equals 1 over 1
minus x, fn of x to be in sum
from j equals 0 n end of xj,
then for all xn
minus 1 to 1, limit
as n goes to infinity of
fn of x equals f of x.
I.e.
this, the sequence of
partial sums corresponding
to this power series,
converges to 1 over 1
minus x point-wise
on minus 1, 1.
So I said, whenever you
come across a definition,
you should negate it.
But the negation
of this definition
is not too difficult.
A sequence of functions
does not converge to
another function point-wise
if there exists
some point, so that
when I stick them
into fn of x, fn of x
does not converge to f of x.
So let's look at
another example, which
is not a power series.
Let's say, we take fn
of x to be x to the n,
where x is in the
closed interval 0, 1.
So what's happening here,
as n gets very large,
there's 1, 1, there's,
I don't know, f 5 of x.
And then, as n gets
very large, these guys
are dropping down
even more and more.
And what is-- are we picking
up something in the limit?
Well, let's look.
Well, if x equals 1,
and it's pretty clear
that the limit as n goes
to infinity of fn of 1,
this equals 1.
If I stick in 1 here,
I get 1 for all n.
And therefore, the limit as n
goes to infinity of fn1 is 1.
Now, if x is in 0,
1, then, I mean,
we've done this limit before.
The limit as n goes to
infinity of fn of x, this
is equal to the limit as n
goes to infinity of x to the n.
Now, x is less than 1.
So x is being raised to a
higher and higher power.
This equals 0.
Thus, what do we conclude?
For all x in 0, 1, this
sequence of functions x to the n
converges point-wise
to the function
f of x, which is
equal to 0 if x is
in 0, 1, and 1 if x equals 1.
So I draw another picture here
of what the limit looks like.
And you can start to see
this, as m gets large,
again, this is becoming
more vertical there.
But then going to 0.
So for any fixed
n, it's converging
to this picture on the right.
And so, we can already pick
up something, or at least
answer one of these
questions, if we take them
as a question about
convergence or functions
in the point-wise sense.
So we could have asked
this question now.
After having this
definition, suppose
fn's are continuous converging
point-wise to a function f.
Is the function f continuous?
And what this example shows is
that, no, that's not the case.
x to the n is always continuous.
Yet, the limit as
n goes to infinity,
the point-wise limit is
given by this function, which
is 0 from 0 to 1, and
1 at x equals 1, which
is not a continuous function.
So already, we're kind of seeing
that point-wise convergence,
which is this first
weakest mode of convergence
that we as of now can
say about power series
and is not good enough to
ensure that the limit is
even continuous.
Because this example
shows that we
have a sequence of
continuous functions
whose point-wise limit
is not continuous.
So as another example,
you should always--
I like this kind
of last chapter,
because you can draw
a lot of pictures.
So I'm going to
draw pictures of fn.
So it's piece-wise linear.
So I can write down
what the function is,
but I don't want to.
I'm just going to
draw a picture.
So fn of x from 0, 1 to R.
This is how it looks.
So there's 1, 1.
And what I do is, I go
to the point, 1 over n.
And the function fn of
x is 0 up until then.
And then, it's a linear function
connecting 1 over n to 2n here.
And then it's connects
this point to n0, so
or I should say, 1 over 2n, 2n,
connects that to the origin.
So that's f sub n of x.
It's just piece-wise linear.
So for example, if
I want to draw f1,
f1 would look like
there's 1, 0, 2, 1/2.
And let's say I
wanted to draw f 100.
What does that look like?
So maybe I should make this
one a little bit bigger.
There's 1, 1 over 100, and
then that should be 1 over 200.
And then if I go up to 200,
is this piece-wise linear
function, which is getting--
it's 0 from 1 up to 1 over 100.
So it's 0 most of the time.
And it's 0 at the origin.
But in between, it's
very tall and very slim.
And so, my claim is
that for all x in 0,
1, limit as n goes to
infinity of fn of x equals 0.
So this sequence of functions
converges point-wise to 0.
So why is this?
Well, let's just give
a full proof of this
rather than me talking it out.
I mean, I'll talk it out
and give a full proof.
So let's look at the
easiest spot first.
And I don't even need the
formula for these guys.
I just need to know that they
have this basic characteristic
that their point-wise
linear, I mean,
that they're piece-wise
linear connecting
0 to 1 over 2n and 2n here,
and then down to 1 over n 0.
And then, there's 0
between that and 1.
So first off, if x equals
0, then all these functions
are 0 at the origin.
So they equals 0.
So that equals 0.
So that's fine.
So now suppose x is in 0, 1.
And so, what do we want to show?
I want to show limit
as n goes to infinity
of fn of x equals 0.
And here, so what's
the point here?
Now, there's 1, there's x.
So I have to give a--
well, I'm not even going to
do an epsilon delta epsilon M
argument.
I'm just going to
show you what happens.
So there's x between 0 and 1.
Now, let's choose a very
large integer so that 1 over M
is less than x.
So here's 1 over M to
strictly to the left of x.
Now, what is the
graph of fn of x
look like for n bigger
than or equal to M?
It's 0 from x equals
1 to x equal 1 over M,
and then shoots up, and then
comes back down over here to 0.
But here's the point.
It's 0 all the way from 1 to
1 over M. So in particular,
at x, fn of x is 0.
So if I look at
this sequence, fn
of x, which I'm trying to
show converges to 0, it is 0--
no, it is a f1 of x, f2 of
x, up to fn minus 1 of x.
And then, at fM
of x, so at the--
now, so this is fM
of x spot, it's 0.
And this point is only
going to the left.
So for all n bigger
than or equal to M,
now this will be 1 over n
will be to the left of x.
And therefore, fn
of x will be 0.
So this is 0, 0,
0, 0, and so on.
So I have the sequence
is eventually 0
for all n bigger than or
equal to capital M. So
and therefore,
the limit, I mean,
it's pretty easy to take a
limit of a constant sequence.
And which proves that
this sequence of functions
converges point-wise to 0.
Now, I didn't come up
with this fancy example
for just any old reason.
It'll come back in
a minute when we
start answering some
of these questions,
or asking them, again, within
the context of these two
convergence--
ways of converging.
So, so far, I've only
given you one definition
of convergence--
point-wise convergence
of a sequence of functions.
And now, I'm going
to give a slightly--
I'm going to give a
stronger-- it's not slightly,
it's much stronger--
definition of convergence
of a sequence of functions.
So we have a sequence of
functions and a given function
from S to R. S is a
non-empty subset of R.
Then we say the sequence
fn converges point-wise
or uniformly to 0--
uniformly to 0-- uniformly to--
it's the end of the day.
If I start mixing
up some of my words,
I'm always going to correct it.
But the first word
out of my mouth
may not be the correct one--
converges uniformly
to f of x to f if--
now we have an
epsilon in statement.
For all epsilon positive, there
exists an M natural number
such that for all n bigger than
or equal to M, for all x in S,
fn of x minus f of x
is less than epsilon.
Now, I want to make
a brief comment.
This looks suspiciously
like point-wise convergence,
if you just wrote down
what it means for the limit
as n goes to infinity of
fn of x goes to f of x.
Except, there's a very
subtle and important point.
And that is, where does
for all x and S appear?
For point-wise
convergence, you can
state point-wise
convergence as this
being at the start of
the line, for all x
in S, for all epsilon
positive, blah, blah, blah.
Here, it appears at the end of
the line of the quantifiers.
And this makes a very
important difference
between point-wise convergence
and uniform convergence.
Point-wise convergence
means, I take a point x,
I stick it into fn of x.
That gives me a
sequence of numbers.
And point-wise convergence
says that sequence of numbers
converges to f of x.
For each x, I get a
sequence of numbers,
which converges to f of x.
Now, uniform
convergence is actually
saying something stronger.
And I'll say that.
So let me, in fact, let
me draw a picture that
goes with this definition.
Let's make S to be an interval.
Let's say my limiting function
is f is given by this graph.
And so, what I'm going
to do is basically
shift the graph up
and down by epsilon,
meaning this length is
epsilon, and so is this length,
all the way across.
So let me shade this
in and re-outline--
oh.
So I get this little,
if you like, shaded area
around my function f.
So this is f, f of x.
That's the graph.
And the shaded part, this
is the set of all x and y,
such that f of x minus
y is less than epsilon.
So I get a little
tube snaking with f.
Now, what uniform
convergence says,
is that for all n bigger than
or equal to some M, so given
epsilon, for all n bigger
than or equal to M, if I were
to draw the graph of
fn of x, it better
fall inside this tube
across all of a, b.
See, this tube is defined
for all x between a, b.
So it's making a statement
about how close fn of x
is to f of x across
the entire set.
Point-wise convergence just
says, if I put an x into fn
of x, then eventually
those numbers
are getting close to f of x.
Uniform convergence
is a global property.
It's saying, across the entire
set, as n is getting large,
the graph of this
fn is getting very
close to the graph of f of x.
Not just if I fix an x,
the fn of x at that point
are converging to f of x.
So I've said a couple of
times that uniform convergence
is stronger than
point-wise convergence.
Let me actually prove this now.
So let me prove that
following theorem.
So if I have a sequence
of functions from S to R,
and fn, rather than
write converges
to f point-wise or uniformly,
I'm going to put an arrow.
And then, with the description
afterwards, uniformly on S.
And then this implies fn
converges to f point-wise on S.
So it's very simple.
Again, what is
the picture that's
going on for uniform
convergence is
that fn is getting close
to f across the entire set
that we're looking at.
So certainly at one
point, which is all
you need for
point-wise convergence.
Each fixed point we
should be getting close.
So let epsilon be positive.
So first off, let's fix
a number in the set S.
So now we want to prove
that the limit as n
goes to infinity of
fn of c equals f of c.
Let epsilon be positive.
Since fn converges
to f uniformly,
there exists a natural
number M0 such that
for all n bigger than or
equal to M0, for all x in S,
fn of x minus f of x
is less than epsilon.
So choose M to be this M0, the
M that is for this epsilon.
Then for all n bigger
than or equal to M,
let's call this equation star,
star with at the single point
x equals at c, implies
fn of c minus f of c
is less than epsilon.
And thus, the limit as n goes
to infinity of f of c, fn of c
equals f of c.
So I don't think I have
enough time to do the example
that I want to do.
So I'm just going to leave
you on the edge of your seat
by stating the
following theorem.
That in fact, so this
is a one-way street.
Meaning point-wise
convergence does not
imply uniform convergence.
So we just proved uniform
implies point-wise.
But the converse does not hold.
And what we'll
prove next time is
for in the setting of this
simple example of x to the n.
So-- and so, what we'll prove
next time is the following.
If I take any b
between 0 and 1, then
fn convergence to f
uniformly on the set 0, b.
So these functions
are defined on 0, 1.
So they're certainly defined
on 0, b for b less than 1.
But however, this
sequence of functions
does not converge
uniformly to f on 0,1.
So here, this second part,
since the fn's converge
to point-wise on 0,
1, the second part
says that this is
a one-way street.
This is not a two-way street.
These two modes of
convergence-- uniform
convergence and point-wise
are not equivalent.
All right.
I think we'll stop there.